joining us right here in person is a man
who is uh hosting season two of tbs's go
big show that premieres the first
thursday of 2022 uh january 6th at 9 00
pm eastern on tbs and he's going on the
road everybody he's going to be leaving
us uh ted to reading california
sacramento and other spots across this
great nation as the relapse tour picks
up where birdie boy tour left off due to
the pandemic ladies and gentlemen put
your hands together for bert crusher
here philadelphia we just added a second
show with the met hey first of all yes
sir uh how many checks are this is that
when you go serious xm mbcp i didn't
mention my podcast or youtube channel
honestly bert i would be
the best head coach
okay uh the best number one on sidekicks
every time on sidekicks
every i want them to know we're doing it
i want i want our our kicker's going to
go on sidekick and then we're going to
do like a little razzle dazzle like and
there's some flair
a lot of flair
you might want to just change the name
of my teams to the flare the flare
because i first of all my halftime
speeches and my pregame speeches are
going to
tears to the eyes like when my
grandmother
passed away at the ripe age of 98 she
said one thing put some pads on people
like it's gonna be great speeches
uh
first person i draft aaron rodgers i'm
throwing the bank at aaron rodgers okay
yes close personal friend close personal
friend okay i met him once and so
by the way i met him like a week before
he got covered
i was like oh so
so now he is you're letting him know
you're coming for him because he might
he might force his way out of green bay
bert kreischer's flare oh he's is is
throwing the bank i am on the road he's
got the best head of hair that is first
of all i'm gonna really i wouldn't be
shocked if our helmets were just aaron
rodgers air okay okay yes uh next person
i pick you ready for this one yes sir
johnny hecker
oh cause you're okay they're punchers
and weapons
nfl player in the league that guy is a
game changer he could be your backup
quarterback too if necessary oh well
first of all yes we're not just we're
gonna do a lot of fake puns on second
down
second down we're in punt formation
they're confused what's going on yes
they all of a sudden have a safety
running back 40 yards like i guess i got
to catch it
fake punt right yeah one second down a
fake have you ever seen a fake falling
on a second down no never never yeah
never i've never seen a punt on set
razzle dazzle
you know what you're gonna have to make
everybody bird crasher sit back and
rethink the concept of what a special
team really is you know what i'm saying
like i think we throw that i think we
throw that around without really
thinking about it yeah you want to put
the special in special i want to put the
special and special thing
that's what i'm getting that's what i'm
picking up i i am going to i'm going to
um force uh celebrations in the end zone
okay force them meaning i will write
them out it'll be a lot that'll be very
elaborate they'll be like okay and
they'll be like costume changes and
really
when i was a kid oh by the way anytime
number one rule on my team birch
pressure yes any fumble the entire team
starts going we got it we got it we got
it doesn't matter if we have it we got
it we got it we got it i just think that
there should be a penalty on anybody who
falsely claims possession of the
football oh we got to stop that bert
cause because it's thrown around willy
nilly you're getting my hopes up i don't
want my hopes up they're then dashed
there should be a penalty i had i played
football when i was in like seventh and
eighth grade my very first play my i was
horrible my very first play interception
ran it back to the one yard line yeah so
they thought i was
like the guy's got a gift
all i wanted to do what fumbles with
this guy
we got it we got it we got it my coach
is like hey man we never had it i was
like i don't know
i returned a punt one time that is
terrifying oh yeah
when a punt when you catch a bun you see
everyone you're standing still yes and
they're sprinting at you yeah it's one
of the most terrifying things i've ever
done in my entire life
yeah
i can't wait to coach the nfl
well you may have an opportunity in
short order bird i mean like right now i
think you're putting your resume out
front and center right now oh you're a
winner you're a winner
i couldn't i could be a minor league
how much does a minor league team cost
in baseball
uh chris you've got the google machine
right there
like single a bird or independent what
do you think what are you
see i don't know if he's thought this
out too deeply
i just had a flash of brilliance
when i thought what if we started a
gofundme to buy a a major league team
for a football team mm-hmm how much the
football team golf oh a lot yeah yeah
baseball bert it looks like you could
get like six seven million
okay
still out of my price range
glad you added one more in philadelphia
i'm gonna be doing a lot of stand up to
support this minor league team i'm
buying all right now we could scrap it
not every idea is a g not every idea is
a gem i like your i like your your
aggressive nature of uh of being a
football coach i kind of dig ed yeah
what if you were the commissioner of the
nfl you could wave
a wand and become and you you could you
a bert christ your rule change could be
instant the owners are meeting today we
could actually i could run this up the
flagpole and see if there's any owner
that would even raise their hand and say
this is my idea i would look like
steroids
[Music]
right green lighting steroids is not i
think in the car but no but but aren't
they like are they good for you too like
well
i know that like with recovery and
whatnot
hgh i think is okay by the way put that
down for a fantasy team green lighting
steroids i would green light steroids
says bird crystal i mean i just think
so people are probably using them anyway
so just make it across the board okay
yeah that's your first order of business
buy my first order
and then last
i would uh
i would outlaw kickoffs i i really want
i love
i love on-side kicks i love them they're
so much fun right and it's so fun to
watch like uh who was playing the other
night um the rams and the cardinals
actually
there were four successful onside kicks
this weekend yeah four of them
did you hear the the last on-site kick
they go um
the two guys on the bottom they're
rookies that's who you want to kick it
to and i'm sitting there going that's
the kind of i love that talk yeah i love
that because that that's exactly how you
oh
and so yeah
i would outlaw just kickoffs all in
general okay any injuries
because basically body's going in bodies
right correct like braveheart meeting at
the center of the field and i i i get
rid of that and then just do onside
kicks i like it hey if you want do
onside kicks on the 20-yard line back
there right you know so are you a bucks
fan are you a buck man okay i'm a bucks
rams fan i couldn't go to the bucks rams
game because i am a bucks fan but my my
whole family were rams fans we have ram
season tickets no kidding have you so
you like have you been in the new
stadium yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we have
what we only want once we have we went
to uh we went into the uh the bottom box
like the one on the field hold on one on
the field yeah where you can just see
the names of the players
i was always wondering if that's a good
vantage point it's not a good seat
it's a lot of fun if you want to drink
next to hip-hop stars because that's all
that's down there is gamers and hip-hop
stars my neighbor i was living probably
shouldn't say that never mind
you have to drop name of your neighbor
my neighbor was it was
a hip-hop guy and he was next like two
doors down and i was like hey guys come
on down party all right and then uh yeah
i was i brought the girls
it's cool to be on the bottom of sofi to
see the grandness of it it's a beautiful
stadium it really is gorgeous um it is a
beautiful stuff and it's a fun it was
really they really take care of you it
was really nice oh good yeah it was a
blast and we had a great time but uh i'm
a
ultimately i'm a diehard boxer okay i
mean and winning last year is one of the
i mean that's as tip-top as you can get
and then tampa i mean they win the cup
they win the cup i have no loyalty to
the other teams because i all we have
were the bucks okay so all we had were
the bucks and then that's it so i had no
civic pride okay but look at kids kids
from boston to philly that love their
city and i'm like i thought you're
supposed to hate your city because your
team sucks
i mean like i have my civic pride i'm
loyal to like like this leroy selman
dewey selman yeah
james giles giles uh
doug i mean
doug williams yes was my hero
like my hero my dad spoke so beautifully
of doug williams skill like when he'd
feather it into the end zone just like a
little
doug williams man that's my hero so do
you do you have anything like popsicle
creamsicle color or you don't have like
shirts the new ones i can't do the new
ones i have no loyalty to that that new
uniform doesn't mean anything computer
you're not into oh i i wanted that salt
because it was such an ugly uniform yes
for so long and then now that's all i
rock if i find them anywhere i buy them
i gotta be honest with you because those
uniforms those old buccaneer where they
got the pirate with his with with the
you know the the dagger in his mouth
that sort of thing from the old sombrero
days and the creamsicle color uniforms
i'm always into the throwbacks i love
throwbacks i love when current players
wear throwbacks putting tom brady though
in that uniform would be kind of
wrong don't you think you feel right
it's like it's like when your wife when
you see a parrot like one time i was
with my wife and we were at the store
and this woman walked in with these
really high boots and i was like the
woman was just gorgeous my wife's like
oh you like those boots and i was like
yeah it's the boots and she's like i'll
get a pair and i was like don't ruin
them don't get
it you know what i mean my wife doesn't
watch this right
she said to me the other day she goes
tiger woods is such a great dad because
he's playing golf with charlie yeah
right yeah i go
yeah of course he's doing the thing he
loves with his son if i could take my
daughters on tour with me and party with
him in my tour but i would excel at it i
would look like an amazing dad
i was like no this is a one-hitter you
just take a little hit and then we go to
bed
and then
like and then wake up in the morning
like hey i got dirty girls for us who
wants a drink
hands are not shaking anymore come on
let's go we're gonna have coffee we're
gonna play pickleball until four in the
morning
like i would be great
that's so good
i love tiger woods too who's your
favorite golfer of all time
yeah i mean okay sure hold on
john daly
hmm we had john here for different
reasons well sure but but john daly we
we it was wild where
i ran into him somewhere
and he's like sure i'll come on your
show i'm like you want to come on my
show and he's like yeah i'm in town i'll
be there you know 10 o'clock on tuesday
and then i would text like are you
coming you coming nothing remember this
chris yeah nothing and then we had no
idea
that we had no idea he's going to show
up and then in the middle of the first
hour i get a text on my phone during a
commercial break john daley just showed
up
in an rv like in an rv it was like where
do i park
dude like give me a heads up we got to
make sure like sure sat down it was
awesome
i said this
i said this i would would you i think
you would say yes but i'm just saying
this now i'm going to put another
question tomorrow okay
would you let him
tea
like hit a driver
off a t
that's in your mouth would you do that
let him if the okay you're lying down on
the ground yeah lying down t is t is in
your mouth
ball on top of the t would you let him
take a full john daly swing
and drive the golf ball off of that
burt crusher
sometimes in life it's not the things
you do it's the things they stop you
from doing
i was in tanzania one time what a great
start here we go kids were uh running
off a wall you can find this on
instagram running off a wall and jumping
20 feet in the air into shallow water
and landing and i thought to myself i
think i could do that i was pretty drunk
i was like i think i can do that and i
talked to some of these kids in it was
in zanzibar yes and and i go and they
were like they're like oh yeah just like
this at the end like this
and and an old lady stopped me and said
don't and i didn't do it
i regret not doing that every day of my
life
because it would have been i could say
that when i was in zanzibar the home of
freddie
mercury that i jumped off that cliff
just like that just like those kids yes
100 percent a hundred percent i would
let john daley tell from my mouth
exactly i would and by the way i would
make my wife do it also
i would go leanne you're up next
because you'd be like wait what i'll be
like yeah come on let's do it let's do
it he wouldn't brockman would you said
no you wouldn't i said absolutely just
let me let me i'm not going to hit you
in the head hold on let me be the
let me be the guy's got club control i
want to be the old lady in zanzibar for
a second okay
you make your livelihood with your mouth
talking okay let's just say maybe john
daly had like
12 extra beers that that means he'll hit
the ball better exactly
and then he like slips what he's
barefoot he plays golf barefoot what if
like it rained that morning and the
dewest and he like slips you're not
reverse engineering this and like he all
of a sudden hits the 10 degree
taylormade
i'm made into your face i make my money
with my mouth only if people show up now
i get hit in the jaw by a golf club by
john daley
the birdie boy recovery tour
are you kidding me i want to see if he
can still tell the machine story
i got involved with the russian mafia oh
my god my heart's breaking he's so good
that's exactly it that is that is viral
right
viral
and for having a broken face bottom line
is he's saying
that if you do it
let it happen and he smokes it 300 yards
down the the fairway you've got a great
story
he's saying if he gets his face broken
into many different spots the website
bertbertbert.com still works yeah and as
a matter of fact more people might
actually go to that spot and get tickets
to his tour yes that is what i'm talking
about and and by the way my mouth's
wired shut for three months i lose some
weight i'm feeling good right
you gotta look at this backwards so are
we purposely telling john to hit you in
the face we're not what he's saying he
wins either way even if you lose your
win
i tell you what i tell well i'll
tell him to do when he hits it out of my
wife's mouth is get real close to the
lips to puff him up
just skim
by the way the offer is out john daly's
listening there you go i would do it i
would still this is what i do ready for
this yes i put the tea in my mouth i lay
back and i go
i've added tour dates to this haul
birdie boy relapse target of perfect
person
that's how that's how he teased it off
when i went to surgery for my elbow this
anesthesiologist said uh what music do
you want to listen to i said uh i said
we could listen to music he said oh yeah
i said i want to hear credence
clearwater revival and just so you know
when you're putting me under i'm not
gonna count backwards because what are
you gonna do i said i'm gonna hold the
phone up and yell off tour dates and go
i'm performing at red rock september 9th
come see me at red rocks and he put me
under with me reading off my dates and
i'll tell you right now i'm kind of
looking for a surgery
i got to show cinco de mayo with the
greek i'm trying to promote
you guys coming out to my show and
singing to my own guess who's gonna be
there aaron rodgers oh now are you
coming yeah yeah we're hanging out
when you take your shirt off like say at
a king's game like we just saw
um and then then do you go back to your
seat in that in that way as well and
then just like what what is the what is
what are the rules here bird are there
any rules in in in terms of when you do
it and how long it's the shortcomings
strip clubs they take their clothes off
and then they leave right they leave
naked yeah because no one wants to see a
stripper put her clothes back on on
stage
that's in theory yes that's the theory
so i do the same thing
i go back to my
shirtless and then
it's the sad moment of me putting my
clothes back on
and my daughter's sitting next to me
going that's our father
and my wife's like that's my man we're
gonna buy a house because of that
well brockman you sit around in your
house at shirtless all the time right
yeah well it's my house so it's my
decision and i i go shirtless at my
house all the time oh i'm a naked guy
like
like i don't wear underwear i never wear
underwear and so i'm a naked guy like if
you let me once the girls go to school
i'm naked i'm like get on the treadmill
sauna naked shower in the backyard naked
walk around naked sit at my desk naked i
love being naked so that's a florida
thing though that is a florida thing i
think sometimes you like go uh that's
florida and i didn't know it you know
like uh like i'll say stuff like oh i
knew two dudes without tongues growing
up and they're like
there
but that's a florida thing my brother
that's a florida thing that's a floor
like florida things like we lit a kid on
fire one time and everyone's like what i
was like yeah his name is johnny we lit
them on fire you didn't like kids on
fire
like it was you know in the 30s this
morning in l.a and you're wearing
flip-flops well i'm not wearing just
flip-flops of course i'm wearing my
flip-flops oh yeah these are my own
brand what are they free water they're
called the dillons but it's my face on
the bottom and they're so comfortable
it's the only flip flop you ever need
i'll get you a pair i'd love that
they're awesome what size are you 10 and
a half done done i will wear them
everywhere martin get them at 10 and a
half martin whoever wherever martin is
these are the
coming out we have 11
shoes but these flip-flops i fell in
love with these flip-flops and i started
hounding the company because they
stopped making them yeah and i was like
please bring them back this is we're
talking like eight years ago i've been
working to get these flip flops back so
they got them back and i said great
i'll i'll sell them for you right uh i
don't need i think i get a cut but like
i'll sell them for you sure because
they're that good i've given them to
everyone rogan loves them arie loves
them the girl loves them everyone loves
it i'm i'm i'm in love i just sent aaron
rodgers that's that right i swear to god
so if he's walking around in flip-flops
then my foot my face is under his foot
you know that's what's going on he's got
a toe so maybe being open toe right now
is helpful for him maybe you can help
him heal potentially he's got a he's got
a he's got a pinky toe issue and if you
have sent him your open toe flip-flop
situation you might be saving the
packers season bert you're welcome i
love to be a part of a team like that
i love to be a part of the solution i
would love to see a picture of this foot
in my flip-flops flip-flop he's showing
off his bare foot on zooms to point out
that he doesn't have coveto that he was
just joking about it on mcafee's show oh
yeah you know and so he holds up his
foot why why can't he hold up his foot
the next time in a bert kreischer like i
would love to see your face on an aaron
rodgers packer zoom
while he's showing off his toe he would
probably do that for you i i would i
would hope if he's watching i'll text
him we can make sure i'll text him at
mcafee to make sure it happens i think
volkswagen mac if he's got the follow
through okay and mcafee aj hawk
yeah they got the bag for it too that's
for sure right yeah yeah well that's a
lot of money it sure is he's the king of
he's a king of all media that's for sure
even in the sports world but we already
knew that about pat yeah such
i well first of all i said i'm pretty
sure i could be a competitive kicker in
the nfl right because i got the i got
the ice water under the veins i love
pressure right yeah and then he was like
no i don't think so and he goes you lack
and this is my favorite word you lack
explosivity
i said really and he said that's the one
thing that separates professional
athletes from the average person
explosivity yes and
and so i've been working on my
explosives well i mean you just told me
you you run into the treadmill naked how
do you not have explosivity there uh
i'm working on my explosivity okay i'm
working on it i think like i get out of
chairs pretty exposed
i love it bert uh
we'll we'll take whatever you know
product you want to give us right here
on the rich i got them coming to you
great bird crusher here on the program
so you were
i've never said this sentence before but
i'll say it you were hanging in the
ukraine with mark hamill like that's
actually the case that's actually the
truth in serbia mark hamill okay serbia
not the ukraine serbia that's where you
shot the machine yeah for three months
when is this coming out uh i don't know
we wrap we
lock picture friday okay i think we
wrapped the movie february so maybe june
we just we've just been testing it it's
really fun to test a movie and see what
works and what doesn't work okay cause
things that you're like that's gonna be
hilarious
the best part my favorite part of
hanging out with mark hamill is first of
all he's a very very generous man like
he is if you ask him any question you
know like sometimes people you know bird
tell this machine story or whatever i'll
tell it yeah but someone like mark
campbell you think you bring up star
wars maybe he's heard these questions a
million times he delivers it to you like
he's never been asked that question how
lovely he gives you everything
you'd want and then the fun stuff like
let me tell you what i love about carrie
fisher or or uh or the other guy
harrison harrison
my favorite part though is my co-lead a
female in the movie is is from
eastern bloc and she never
saw star wars and she said she says to
me i've never seen star wars don't bring
it up please don't bring it up and i go
for real she goes i don't i don't want
to be embarrassed so i go okay so if you
sit down for dinner and i go uh eva
you're a big star wars fan right
she goes
oh yes i love it it's such a wonderful
film mark and mark goes oh well uh well
what did you like about it oh you know
typical good guy bad guy thing okay
and then i go eva who's your favorite
character in star wars she goes um
probably chewbacca and i go oh cool good
she's she's she's making it through
right here yeah and then mark goes to
change the subject i go hold on mark
eva can you do an impression of
chewbacca oh she goes oh of course
hi i'm chewbacca
more falls out
you've never seen the movie have you
ever
i'm
we had the best time i would tell this
to anyone who ever makes a movie
don't worry about losing weight you know
what you do why i was just fat in the
movie i just gained more weight after
the movie now i watch it i'm like i look
great
all these people are losing weight for
movies just gain weight after the movie
yeah you think you look fantastic that's
a great way to approach and then people
go you look you look healthy burn i said
i'm getting away from a movie and
they're like which one i already shot it
i just want to make sure i look good in
it when i look at it so yeah uh it was a
blast mark hamill i was with his wife
and his uh daughter
all the time we all hung out
very cool like and you'd say like i i
threw house parties every night like
roughly
and roughly hopefully and you'd i'd
always extend an invitation to mark
thinking he probably won't come right
shut up every time
shut up every time that's amazing yeah
he's like
the i did i did i am a little bit of a
[ __ ] like i didn't know there was a
dude inside r2d2
right there's an actual person yes right
and then i also didn't i just assumed
the same with steve 3po and he was like
no those were people bert and he goes
wait how did you think they moved
i don't know i never thought about that
with a joystick yeah and i was like but
when c-3po was on the back of chewbacca
and empire strikes back like
and he goes
bert
did we just that's that's not a real
person we didn't cut a person in half
like he
he literally had to explain a lot of
that movie
what about ewoks did you get on that
subject with him about uh where there
are real people inside the ewoks
i'm not much of a listener rich
i love that
i like to talk about myself you should
check out two bears one cave where tom
just listens to me rattle off for an
hour every day yeah it's uh i i i think
that if you meet someone like mark
hamill you'd pick his brain but i just
told him about me how did you get him to
do it uh we did we had a zoom we because
he plays your father in this he plays my
father
and so we had a zoom
and i think he was on the fence and
the first thing he said was the first
thing my dad said he knows why do you
take your shirt off on stage and that
that's the first thing my dad said he
was why would you do that just first
thing my daughters when they found out i
took my shirt off they'd go you take
your shirt off and it was like i was
like yeah they're like why would you do
that and so the second he said that i
was like he's perfect so we just we're
like anything please because if he's
playing your father and he uses the
first thing that your father says he
kills it he or she does i think people
are going to think this is the best
movie mark hamill's ever
well certainly from the eastern bloc
i think people are going to be like star
what
i i'm more fond of him in the machine
personally
oh man he did this we had this great
scene where uh he does the thing and uh
i don't i can't give away too much but
we have a moment right
and he does it we're doing his close-up
and i just start crying like in real
life i just cry just so he's so good
right then and then they're like oh
that's it's such a great scene then i
slip around let's get birds close up and
i go
oh and they're like can you cry again
and i go i don't know and they're like
what and so i go to mark i go mark can
you do the thing where you oh you did
this thing with your eyes where you like
went like this a little bit and i don't
flex the underneath and you touch my
face can you do that and he goes
you mean act
and i go
yeah and he goes you want me to act so
you can act and i went kind of and he
goes sure
that's what professional actors do
i wonder if he said that to alec
guinness back in 1975 you know oh my
gosh so funny bert crutcher here on the
rich eisen show the go big show uh
season two what what do you want folks
to know about that one it's fantastic we
added t-pain
um he's on it uh
it's just it's just a fun show i mean
it's it what i love about the show is
it's a hold my beer type show
so
if all those things that you see on the
internet where the guy goes hold my beer
i think i can break a vacuum cleaner
over my nuts that's what we do
and it's this season and i really it's
funny because you want
you want stunts where you think the
guy's gonna die
right but then when you do the stunt and
you think this guy might die
it's not quite as fun because you're
like if he does die we're done like like
you don't want anyone to die but you
want to think they're going to die and
there are
easily five acts where
you go this person
very well could die right now very well
could die and but and you want that but
also when you're in the in the movement
moment you're like i don't want anyone
at the end you're right when you're
actually hosting this thing when they
live you're like he almost died i mean
there's one guy there's one guy that uh
legit legit i thought he was gonna die
and then when he did it he does his
thing i started crying because i was
like that was just so amazing to watch
it's it's a fun show and that's again uh
premieres thursday january 6 9 pm
eastern on tbs so um very very rare
opportunity for me to ask a guest to
correct the record last time you were on
here burke you slimed my uh childhood
idol and don mattingly telling a story
where he apparently uh treated you
poorly in the stands uh of a game once
and i was so
upset about it that that my guy who i
thought would never have that sort of
thing in him and then you hit me up
afterwards saying oh yeah that wasn't
don after all this is dave mattingly
dave magnan maggot
i'm not good with names i once got to
fight with a guy who looked like louis
ck and i told my wife
the story but i said that he looked like
louis anderson
and the whole time my wife said this
doesn't sound threatening at all and i
was like no i mean louie's a big guy
yeah you know and she's like well he is
a big guy and i go yeah with his red
hair it's like are you talking about
different louis yeah no it was dave
madden
megaden and he did what did they do me
and scott were running they were called
player appreciation and so we were
running
from home plate to the signs each sign
that was an advertisement and
i tried an example of beer and just and
he's telling me a story about the
weekend and then just a f a line drive
hits him in the back just then he hits
the ground and hit he was with fred
mcgriff i think
i mean by the way um
sounds about right though but i don't
think fred mcgriff from tampa i think he
went to jefferson i think they're the
same age i think that's it yeah and so
he was with fred mcgriff that makes
sense and so yeah i can i remember this
car he had a he had a really nice
big-bodied mercedes yes magadan did okay
um and so beau beer was like oh my gosh
hit by baseball and then they're they're
like oh sorry
and we're like okay so we keep running
and then beers tell me that story and he
gets hit again by a baseball and this
time they're like god i did it but yeah
and magadan obviously if if you don't
remember it that way whatever poor
mattingly had to deal with me saying
that he's like i've never even been to
tampa jesuit what's that
dave magdalene
oh man bert this has just been that's
the problem when you tell a story like
that like i have a story about snoop so
i was working with snoop and we got done
one day and he goes uh
he gets in his trailer and he goes hey
you want to shower
and i was like huh he says come on let's
do a shower
and then goes in his things so i go over
and i'm
asking his bodyguard i'm like uh bossman
says he wants to shower he's like yeah
inside and then i go in snoop sarah and
he's like what's up i said nothing he
goes how do you want to do this i was
like
i don't know i've never done it and he
goes you've never done this and i was
like no i've never i've never done it he
goes come on i don't believe that and i
was like i mean like high school like
you know but not like not recently and
he goes well
let's do it everything would be fun i go
okay and he goes okay you want to do it
at the same time because of course we're
doing at the same time i was like what's
that small shower it's this trailer
i was like okay i thought maybe you
could start and then i'd go and go no
everyone does it at the same time
i go fine and i go let's go and he goes
go where i sit in the shower he goes why
i thought you you wanted to shower and
he goes no
i said let's do a shot
and then snoop is frozen and he goes
you came over here to shower with me
and i was like yeah
i was like i'm a big fan he goes no no i
want to i wanted to do a shot and i was
like oh let's do a shot and i was like i
don't know if i want to do a shot
anymore
there's no way out after that no no i'm
thinking i was like oh yeah you would do
shots at the same time
so we ended up doing a shot
but by the way snoop might not remember
it though
shout out to big snoop i love him
oh my god
i was like maybe we'll do a shot and
shower oh my gosh i'm a pretty thing so
you were hanging with aaron rodgers you
gave him some of your shoes that could
actually save his season your flip-flops
i don't know what we need to put up on
the screen i don't know if you saw this
on sunday night football uh
but uh he he is uh actually got a
doppelganger in uh in
perhaps you gave it to that guy instead
you sure it was the real aaron rodgers
that you saw in your your show and he
was he was that guy on the left the guy
from the left's name is frank who's
actually gotten quite a bit of run on
social media over the last few years
the punter for the texans looks like
bill burr that's true too oh yeah
they're doing doppelganger yep that was
uh i think kyle brandt did that on uh
good morning who's our big lineman for
um uh peter just turned 40 for uh andrew
whitworth looks like tom sagura
these are all good things who do i look
like
probably tom brady a little bit
well certainly in that i'm definitely
gonna look like a lineman certainly in
that shirt
white and i'm fat
no offense to all the linemen out there
i don't even look like a long snapper
yeah snappers are jacked right they're
always like weightlifting coaches this
is what we call bringing it full circle
you're a head coach bro
you're head coach we've already figured
out that you've got a style people going
to want to play for you like a bum
phillips i'm going to be i'm going to
have an outfit like oh a hat get a hat
definitely
get a hat see now we're into it i i how
how hard is it for me to really become a
head coach just a figure head coach like
you know like let me look at some of the
coaches now it shouldn't be that hard i
don't
know
i don't know go to jacksonville go to
jacksonville yeah what if i'm more like
okay how about this soft pitch
our coach mcvay right yes i am your hype
man so all the coaching that he does i
don't want him have to focus on all the
inspirational stuff i want him to focus
on the game he'll be able to focus on
the game i will focus on the razzle
dazzle and the inspirational stuff he
doesn't have to say anything to any
players when they come off field after
good play i'll give him a smack on the
ass yeah great great job yeah i can do
all the extra stuff a coach needs to do
yes but probably shouldn't do in this
multi-million dollar business this is
making sense isn't it yes it is he also
has you know he has the guy he has a he
has a get back guy every coach is a get
back guy because coaches and
particularly mcveigh and this guy was
apparently ripped right stacked with
that right that mcveigh some of the
coaches because they're so into it
they're when they talk to the team the
players on the field they'll stroll
across the uh the end line there the the
sideline and they'll stroll onto the
field which is a penalty they needed
somebody to notice where he is
physically spatially and pull him back i
need one of those when i drink
you ever get like have you ever drink
and then you sit down with your wife and
you go i know something's bothering me
and i know i'm gonna pick a fight about
this one thing that's bothering me i
need it that's when my get that guy just
goes all right get back get back get
back into the bedroom put him down
break his hands put it in his mouth he's
going to sleep he's out he's out we're
good we're good
get back guys you needed that before
your ex-wife threw an emmy at you i'm
just gonna say i need you to get back
his ex-wife threw one of his emmys and
broke it by throwing it out i'm in a
fight
yeah that happened across my house in
encino like literally
full and you know there's wings on that
thing that can hear really can really
hurt oh i got cut that can really hurt
you
go to the hospital what happened it's an
emmy
you have to take a moment to gloat
before explaining what happened it's got
to feel good getting the stitches in
there like so what did you win an emmy
for
[Laughter]
oh my god everybody check out again
season two of the go big show thursday
january 6th at 9 eastern time on tbs uh
the relapse tour picked up where the
birdie boy tour has left off um starting
uh this thursday in redding california
and then tickets and additional dates
can be found at bertbertbert.com
host of the uh bert cast um and so much
like i mean i could literally spend the
rest of your time by talking about what
this is
it really is i told you this this is you
know this is the best thing thank you
appreciate you saying that at burt
kreischer you should follow him on
twitter and instagram i do all of that
good stuff right here on the rich eisen
show hey you watched all the way to the
end thanks for that watch more right
here